the centerpiece of Berlin's three-day
celebration marking the 25th anniversary
of the fall of the Berlin Wall is an art
installation called Licht Grantha where
each thousand balloons allowed people to
visualize exactly how this ancient city
was divided sometimes in the middle of a
street by a massive and screw Tabo and
seemingly endless column of cement Licht
grins a' is the work of berlin based
artists and brothers christopher and
mark powder we live in berlin for about
1516 years now and we will provide
surprised when we moved here that the
ball was almost completely gone and we
were thinking to use something very
opposite to the wall
something very lie it's very easy
something rather positive each balloon
is sponsored by a patron and includes a
note of remembrance and reflection on
the time when Berlin was two cities and
East Germany was a walled-in prison
typical Memorial days when there is a
central organization a central topic a
senseless place where you meet at a
central time for one hour and then
there's a speech to total opposites so
there's boards giving you short stories
about the wall people who died at the
wall and all the people teach to younger
ones what really happened at this
position but we want to bring back to
the history to places where really
history took part it's like here the
Reichstag was on the west side the
building on the left side was on the
east side we wanted to separate a city
to get the people who live here or the
visitors the feeling of what it meant
that streets were separated that people
were separated and then to celebrate at
the end this is the relief the fall of
the wall on the night of November 9th
2014 hundreds of thousands of people
poured into the streets of Berlin
waiting for the moment where one by one
balloons would be released ending the
installation in joyful celebration it
may not have reached 1989 levels of
ecstasy but the freedom and unity
spawned that night were enjoyed by the
throngs who drank and sang and
contemplated the cold war times that
generations of Germans accepted as
reality only to end suddenly with a big
party